hé hallo
ehm nou het is bijna pasen dus ik Wil eigenlijk eh
deze video over pasen doen
mijn pasen is Jezus gestorven aan het kruis
hij is opgestaan na 3 dagen uit De Dood
en in matteus 16 vers 19 heeft Jezus het over sleutels
hij geeft de disciples sleutels
en dit zijn de sleutels
van het koninkrijk van de hemel
en dat staat in matthè 16 vers 19
die geeft IE aan de discipline
eigenlijk geeft IE die aan
Uhm
petrus het wordt eigenlijk aan petrus ook nog gegeven
en Uhm
ik vind het wel
ik vind het heel mooi want in het
uh Nieuwe Testament
nadat Jezus is opgestaan uit De Dood
uh heeft IE het in openbaringen
nog 1 keer over de sleutels
maar deze keer heeft IE het over de sleutels
uh van De Dood en van de dodenrijk luister maar
ik Ben de eerste en de laatste
ik Ben degene die leeft
ik was dood maar ik leef nu en tot 1 eeuwigheid
ik HEB de sleutels van De Dood en van het dode rijk
dus Jezus die is gestorven
hij is afgedaald naar het dodenrijk
hij heeft Satan op de kop gemept
hij heeft de sleutels afgepakt
en hij heeft De Dood eigenlijk verslagen op
uh ja op het eigen terrein van De Dood
en uh
hij heeft laten zien dat hij machtiger is dan De Dood
en hij heeft die sleutels
die uh geeft hij eigenlijk aan ons
Uhm hij geeft de sleutel van de hemel aan ons
voordat hij dood ging
en Uhm hier in het daarna in openbaringen
geeft hij uh
heeft hij de sleutels van De Dood en van de dode rijk
dus als wij hem aanroepen als wij in hem geloven uh
als wij uh luisteren naar zijn woord en Uhm
het belijden
met onze tong dat Jezus Christus onze heer is
onze verloser
onze vriend Uhm
geeft hij die sleutels ook aan ons
de sleutels van het hemelrijk om gave en talenten
te gaan gebruiken en uh
om ook in autoriteit te staan om zijn geesten ontvangen
zijn krachten ontvangen en Uhm
daarin werkzaam te zijn
en Uhm
ja ik vind het zo mooi dat
in dat hij ook die sleutels van het dodenrijk heeft
en dat wij niet meer bang hoefden zijn voor De Dood
we hoeven niet meer na te denken van
wat gebeurt er als ik dood GA want we
want we weten als we in Jezus geloven
hij heeft die sleutels
dan eh zullen wij bij hem zijn tot in alle eeuwigheid
en soms komen er nog wel eens mensen tegen
die dan zeggen van ja
maar ik weet niet of ik goed genoeg Ben voor de hemel
of nee
dat is niet zo als jij gelooft in Jezus
Ben jij gered
en dat staat ook in uh romeinen
romeinen 10 verse 8
het woord is dichtbij u in uw mond en in uw hart
dat betekent
de boodschap van het geloof die wij verkonden is
verkondigen is dichtbij u
als uw mond beleid
dat Jezus Christus de Heer is en u hard gelooft
dat god hem uit De Dood heeft opgewekt
zult u worden gered
want er staat ieder die de naam van de Heer aanroept
zal gered worden
en hoe kom je tot geloof
dus door te luisteren komt mijn tot geloof
en wat mijn hoort is de verkondiging van christus
en de roep klinkt over de hele wereld
dus iedereen heeft echt wel de kans om het geloof
te horen en er staat zelfs ook nog
uh aan Het Eind van de romeine 10 in vers 20 staat ook
bij je zaya staat zelfs ik HEB me laten vinden door
wie mij niet zochten
en ik HEB me bekend gemaakt
en wie niet naar mij hebben gevraagd
dus we hebben genoeg kansen om te horen over god
en god
openbaart zich soms zelf ook wel
aan mensen die helemaal niet op zoek zijn naar hem
dus ik hoop gewoon dat deze video jou ook weer
mag bemoedigen en Uhm
dat je dus eigenlijk weet dat je heel veel
autoriteit hebt in Jezus
omdat we die sleutels hebben ontvangen
we hebben zijn kracht
hebben wij ontvangen en in die autoriteit
mogen wij dus ook gaan staan
fijn pasen allemaal